my best Spanish Fino is the final
restaurant to stay elimination in the
face they barely put a foot wrong in
their heat head chef Nevers produces
authentic Spanish food has impressed
everyone
my undercover critic Simon Davis is
there to save their care their standards
up
ah at the poor forget us
yeah incredible might say gudinas blown
away but listen to the atmosphere in the
background
yeah it's buzzing and you can't buy the
hammer sphere really good start but in
his main course my secret diner detects
signs of over seasoning
a little bit
the first bit of negative feedback for
my tigre Donna slightly clumsy on the
seasoning or shave I told all four
restaurants to expect my call they know
that I'm looking for perfection but only
two will survive this stage it's the
moment of truth I am nervous whether
we've done enough I can't a car so that
let's hope so
may I speak to Sam please how are you
Sam I'm very well thank you how are you
yeah not bad thanks not bad
hi it is yes nervous yeah unfortunately
the couple of dishes were slightly
heavy-handed with the seasoning I'm
concerned about all our staff I want to
see restaurants get better and climb
across this competition and you and you
is not going to the next stages all
right sorry Stefan is really my area and
him I think we lost lost it to go
through to the next round because of
that just I think like you probably do
sorry
Talia you want to do your best now yeah
Sam I'm sorry
unfortunately I have to eliminate two
restaurants from this competition and
it's about to get even harder for phyno
because just to to the next stage of
this competition
congratulations
I was good I mean when Lex is shaking so
it's a good sign it's good